Okay, so good morning. This morning we
are doing the Protestant Reformation.
And I'll explain to you how it gave
birth to capitalism.
Um, this class, it's going to be hard
conceptually because we're we're going
to take concepts we learned before and
combine them to help explain the world
we live in today.
So, if there's anything I'm saying
that's unclear
or
um, confusing
or debatable
please interrupt me, okay? All right, so
I want to make sure that you can follow
the logic clearly. Okay, so um, first of
all, what I will do is is explain the
three major differences between the
Protestant religion and the Catholic
religion, okay?
So, let's look at Catholic first.
In many ways, the Protestant religion is
a response to the problems created by
the Catholic religion, okay? So, there
are three main characteristics
about the Catholic religion. The first
is the idea of orthodoxy.
Or dogma.
Okay?
So, there's a set of beliefs in the
Catholic religion that you must
memorize. You're not allowed to question
it. You're not allowed to interpret it.
You must memorize it, okay? And what
maintains the orthodoxy is the idea of
hierarchy.
So, only
priests and the ordained, those
sanctioned by the Catholic Church, have
access to the Bible. Only they can
interpret the Bible properly.
They are favored by God. The Pope is the
is God's official representative on
Earth.
Okay, so that's the idea of hierarchy.
The last concept um, is the idea
justification
by works.
Okay?
Um and the idea here is, if you want to
be saved, you have to
engage in the proper rituals.
You have to do what the church tells
you. Your actions matter more than your
beliefs.
Okay?
Now,
as we discussed in previous classes,
these three main concepts that underpin
the Catholic Church,
they will create problems. Okay? Um
the So, so justification by works, it
creates a problem of
hypocrisy.
All right? And the idea here is,
it'd be nice if you believed in God.
It'd be nice if you believed in what you
were doing, but you don't have to. Okay?
As long as you do what you're told,
you can still go to heaven, okay? It
creates the idea of hypocrisy. And
obviously, there are a lot of people who
are opposed to this.
All right? Hierarchy creates a problem
of corruption.
There's no real mechanism
to prevent the priests from abusing
their powers. And as we discussed last
week, the priests do engage in a lot of
corruption and um
abuses, okay?
The problem of autocracy is it creates
disconnection.
All right? And the idea here is that
um ever since the dawn of human history,
we humans
are fundamentally religious. Our
fundamental, our first and foremost need
is to connect with God, to be with God,
to work with God, and to access God,
okay? And that's And because of these
three problems, this connection,
corruption, hypocrisy, there's always
been dissent, there's always been
rebellion against the Catholic Church in
Europe. Remember last week we discussed
the Cathars, the Waldensians.
All right, so this has been an ongoing
issue in the Catholic Church. So, the
Protestant religion was developed in
response
to these problems, okay? So, let's look
at the three major responses of the
Protestant religion.
Okay. The first response to orthodoxy is
direct access.
You don't need the priest to tell you
what the Bible means. You can just read
it by yourself. In fact, God wills that
you
talk to him directly
by reading the Bible, okay?
If that is the case, then the church
must be fundamentally egalitarian.
Because if everyone can access God, then
everyone is equal in the eyes
of God.
But the fundamental demand now is
justification
by faith.
You have to truly believe
in God.
You must
develop your life around this faith in
God, okay?
So,
on one hand, the Protestant religion is
solving a lot of problems created by the
church.
But on the other hand, it's also
creating a lot of problems as well,
okay? So, let's go over quickly over
some of the major problems. Um
if it's justification by faith, it
creates a problem of
anxiety.
Why? Because
how do you know you truly believe in
God?
Does that make sense? How do you really
know you have faith?
You have to casually prove to yourself
that you truly believe in God
through actions, through works.
Okay? You have to raise doubt in your
mind, and this makes you anxious. It
makes you antic, okay?
So, that's one huge problem
created by
uh Prot- the Protestant religion.
The second big problem is a problem of
diversity.
If everyone is equal, then everyone can
start his or her own religion.
And what we will see during the
Protestant Reformation is an explosion
of different religions with all the- all
different sets of beliefs.
There's only one Catholic church, but
there's like tens of thousands of
Protestant denominations.
Okay?
Um does that make sense? Okay? All
right. So,
then with direct access,
you are forced to have literacy, okay?
You are forced to educate yourself.
All right? And this is a good thing,
right? But it's also a problem because
if you're poor, you may not have access
to education.
All right?
So, this is a problem for a lot of
people. And that's why
um in the beginning of the development
of Protestants Protestantism, most of
the adherents to this new religion were
actually the aspirational middle class.
The people of some means, the people who
want to aspire to more wealth. Okay? So,
this is the basic rundown of the
differences between the Protestant
religion and the Catholic religion. All
right?
All right. Um any Are you clear about
this? Are any any questions so far?
Is this clear to you?
Okay. All right. So, now I'm going to go
deeper, explain the problems that this
new religion creates in the minds of the
faithful, okay? The the the faithful.
All right.
Okay. So, the problem
that
it within the
Christian religion, as we discussed in
previous classes, is the idea of the
Holy Trinity.
Okay, the Holy Trinity.
The idea of the Holy Trinity is that
Jesus,
um, God,
and the Holy Spirit.
These are different forces that are
independent of each other,
but they are equal to each other, and
they're part of the same thing, okay?
So, for the human mind, the way that our
human minds are designed, it is
impossible for us to understand this
concept of the Holy Trinity. It's like
saying that this pen, it is here and not
here.
Your mind has to believe that this thing
is here and not here.
And your mind can't do that, okay? Your
mind has to believe in one thing, and
and you it cannot believe in
contradictions. But, this is inherently
a contradiction.
The only way that our mind can process
this
is by believing that this is a symbol.
Okay?
The reason why is that this is something
The only way that we can understand Holy
Trinity is to believe that it is both
nothing and everything.
Okay? And that's what a symbol is. A
symbol is nothing that represents
everything, depending on how you
perceive it.
The problem with this
is that
it creates the problem of
anxiety.
Right?
Anxiety.
Why does it create anxiety? Because
again, our fundamental need is to
connect with God. And the concept of the
Holy Trinity
means that we can never truly connect
with God. It is a symbol. It is an
abstraction removed from us. We never be
intimate with God.
It's either away from us or through us,
but we can never touch it. We can never
feel it, okay? This creates anxiety.
Before, this was not a problem because
the church
stood between you, the believer,
and the Holy Trinity, okay? All you had
to do was believe in the church, and you
were fine.
But
then, what happens if you get rid of the
church? Now, you you have to grasp with
grasp try to grasp what the Holy Trinity
is. And again, remember, one of the main
um ideas of the Christian religion is
that you must struggle with your faith.
You must re-recognize
and fully realize your faith in God.
Otherwise, you'll be condemned to hell.
But as we have already discussed,
this Holy Trinity is impossible to
understand.
Okay? So, this creates anxiety.
Now,
the thing about anxiety is
it creates
um
the the problem of like OCD,
okay? Obsessive
compulsive
behavior.
Because
anxiety
um comes about because of confusion,
okay? What you want to do is remove this
anxiety by ordering your physical world.
Right? People with obsessive compulsive
behavior, what do they do? They like to
clean houses.
They like to buy things. They like to
lose weight. They're trying to order the
word we use is rationalize.
They're trying to rationalize
the world around them
in order to
reduce anxiety. Okay?
All right? Does that make sense?
All right? Have you studied obsessive
compulsive behavior?
OCD. All right? It's caused by It's
caused by anxiety and this anxiety
forces you to try to rationalize the
world.
All right? Now, there's also a third
problem
in the Protestant religion. And it's the
idea of
double
pre-
destination.
All right? Okay. So, this is a big
concept, but but it's very easy to
understand.
If you remove the church because the
church is too corrupt,
the problem arises like, how do you know
if you're going to heaven or not?
Who's going to decide?
And so, a man a theologian by the name
of John Calvin, he proposed the idea of
double predestination. And the idea here
is this.
God at the beginning of time has already
decided.
And this decision is final. You cannot
persuade him
that he is wrong because he is perfect,
eternal, and immutable.
And
only a few, the elect, will be saved.
Only Only these people will be allowed
to go to heaven. Everyone else will be
condemned to hell.
And who are the elect? The elect are
those who truly believe
that they have been saved.
Only those who truly believe in God's
mercy and God's grace will be saved.
Okay?
If you think about it,
this creates even more anxiety.
Because
how do you know if you're one of the
saved? You have to work hard now to
solve this problem.
Okay?
So, let's summarize.
Because of the Protestant religion, you
have three new problems
created. The first is the individual
believer cannot understand the Holy
Trinity, but they must. That's what the
religion demands. That's the first
problem. Second problem is the anxiety
causes OCD, which makes them want to
rationalize the world. It makes them
want to order the world according to
their faith. Okay? That's the second
issue. The third issue is that you have
double predestination, that where which
says that if you do not truly believe in
God, if you have if you do not actually
figure out
the grace of God, then you'll be
condemned to eternal damnation.
Okay? So, these are the three major
problems created by the Protestant
religion.
And so, over time, okay? And this is a
process that will take decades,
centuries. They figure out a solution.
All right, they figure out a solution.
And the solution is this.
The solution is money.
Sorry.
Money.
Okay?
The solution is money.
That's how you resolve these three
paradoxes or three contradictions, three
anxieties. All right. So, first of all,
let me explain what money is.
Okay?
Money.
All right.
So,
in the world, we are all
different. We have different
perspectives, okay?
Um
So, each individual is unique. Each
individual is different. Each individual
sees the world
differently.
And this creates confusion. This creates
problems, okay?
I might ask you
why you're in school, you might say,
"Oh, I'm here to learn mathematics." I
might ask someone else like, "Oh, I want
to go to America for college." Another
person might be like, "I want to learn,
okay?" Each person is different.
Okay? But, what happens is this.
If I introduce the concept of money,
what it does is it standardizes,
systematizes,
clarifies, and simplifies everyone's
understanding into one
concept, into a
coherent whole.
Okay? So, let me use an experiment to
show you
like why this is true.
All right. So, some experimenters, they
gave everyone a wine test. They put
three different bottles of wine in front
of each person, asked each person to
taste the wine, and then asked each
person which wine is the best.
And most people
could not
tell the difference. They were
different. They were These were
different bottles of wine, but they
didn't know which one was better.
Okay?
Then, what the experimenters did was
they put price tags on each bottle of
wine, okay? $10,
$20,
$50.
And then, when the experimenters did
this, everyone knew, "Oh,
of course, the $50 bottle of wine is
better, okay?" So, that's what money
does. Man, money allows us to simplify
the world to in order to understand it.
Okay? So, all our beliefs
all our values, all our judgment now is
placed into this one symbol, money.
But then what happens is we then take
this money and we reshape
the world according to money.
Okay, does that make sense? Now I ask
you, why are you going to school?
Everyone's like, "To make money in the
future."
Everyone agrees on this.
Okay?
So, that's what money is. Money is a
system to standardize everyone's
thought.
And then once the standardization
happens, it reshapes reality into a
rational order.
Okay, does that make sense?
All right? Okay, so let's go back.
Okay, now that we understand what money
is, we can now explain how money reduces
the paradoxes.
Right? Money is a way for people to
rationalize the world. You're You're
anxious? What do you do to re- to reduce
this anxiety? Make money.
Make more money.
Don't stop until you make the most
money, okay?
Then
money is a way to resolve the God issue.
Because money is also a symbol. So, what
you can do mentally is conflate God with
money. Money is God.
God is money. That makes sense to
people.
Right?
And now, because you've conflated God of
money, you can now solve the
predestination problem, which is like,
"Oh,
how do I know I have faith in God?"
Because I have a lot of money. Because I
spent my entire life accumulating money.
And how do I know I'm going to have it?
Because I'm rich.
Well, my wealth shows that I have true
faith in God. If I have true faith in
God, then I must be one of those
predestined by God to be the elect.
And therefore, I have nothing to worry
about.
All right?
And because of this, the beauty of this
system is this. It creates a concept of
capitalism.
Never before in human history have
people people believed that this is a
good thing. That that you should go
accumulate money for the sake of
accumulating money, okay? Before it was
always about accumulating money in order
to increase your social status.
Wealthy people would always spend their
money holding community feasts.
Okay? On giving money to the the poor.
On helping the community.
So, remember Julius Caesar, when he
died, he was the wealthiest man in the
world, but he gave a third of his money
to the poor people of Rome. He gave a
third of his money to building parks for
Rome.
Okay? And the And the the the the final
third went to um his adopted heir, um
Octavian, okay?
All right? But now, what's important is
that you try to accumulate as much money
as possible. Don't waste it. Because if
you waste it, it's corruption. It shows
you lack the faith in God.
All right?
And that's why we have capitalism.
Because of the anxiety created by the
Protestant Reformation.
All right? And again, um this is a
process that will take centuries. It
doesn't happen right away. Okay? But
it's a process that takes centuries, and
it's and it's a process that will
define the world we live in today.
Okay? Even though today
most people actually not Protestant,
most people do not believe in double
predestination,
most people
um
don't really understand the Holy
Trinity, most people don't want to
rationalize the world.
We have absorbed this mentality.
Okay?
We believe that we should accumulate
money for the sake of accumulating
money.
That's why we worship people like Jack
Ma, Elon Musk, Jeff Bezos. Even though
if you think about it,
they've just accumulated a symbol,
right? The money is actually nothing.
But we worship them because we believe
that money is reality itself.
All right, that's what capitalism is.
Capitalism is a belief that money is
reality
in itself.
All right, so
um
I know conceptually this is hard and
this is a lot, but and now what I will
do is explain historical context,
explain the evidence for this argument.
But first I I want to make sure that
this argument is clear to you. This is a
thesis, okay? This is
This is an explanation as to why we have
capitalism today.
All right, so um
any questions?
Before I explain the historical context.
Is this all clear? Okay, good. All
right.
So now what I'm going to do is
uh
explain the historical context as well
as provide the
um
evidence, okay? All right. So, the
Protestant Reformation.
All right, so the Protestant Reformation
is a process
that
took place from 1517. 1517 is when the
theologian Martin Luther published his
95 thesis. His The
thesis is a direct criticism of the
Catholic Church,
uh the corruption of the Catholic
Church. And it ends really in the year
1648. This is after decades of
um violent warfare between the
Protestants and the Catholics. And at
this point Europe is completely
exhausted. They just finished fighting
something called the 30 Years' War,
which is before World War I,
the deadliest war in European history.
It kills at most about 8 million people.
So, all of Europe is completely
devastated. In certain parts of Germany,
which which is where the war was fought,
they lost about half of the population.
Okay? And this war ended in something
called the Treaty of Westphalia, the
Peace of Westphalia, which guarantees
religious freedom to everyone
in Europe. And this ends the Protestant
Reformation. Okay? All right.
So,
again, uh
historians state the beginning of the
Protestant Ref- Reformation to Martin
Luther. Uh well, we Last week we we
discussed the Crusades, and we discussed
how
um there were
um
many thinkers, theologians who opposed
Catholic Church,
uh people like John Wycliffe, Jan Hus,
um and they were eventually condemned as
heretics, and their rebellion was
stomped out by the Catholic Church. But
Martin Luther, um he's fortunate in that
he has powerful political patrons.
The various princes of the Holy Roman
Empire want more autonomy from the
Catholic Church, and Martin Luther gives
them a proper pretext in order to
financially divorce themselves from the
Catholic Church, okay? So, as I
discussed,
what he's most famous for is something
called the 95 thesis, which is a direct
criticism of the corruption of the
Catholic Church. At this time,
the Catholic Church wanted to build St.
Peter's Basilica, a church in the
Vatican. And they wanted this to be a
gorgeous building. So, to finance the
building of this church, the um Catholic
Church sold something called
indulgences. Indulgences are basically
like tickets or
um
um special letters that will reduce
the punishment of your relatives in
purgatory, okay? It's It's basically to
reduce the number of sins you committed.
It's It's It's It's basically like
bribing God. Okay? To reduce your your
penalty. And this was a very popular
thing. It allowed uh the Pope to build
St. Peter's Basilica, which is one of
the most beautiful buildings in the
world today. But as you can imagine, if
you are true Christian, you are
insulted. You're offended. Um
you're angered by the idea of this
corruption, okay? So, the 95 Theses uh
are 95 sentences in which in which um
Martin Luther lays out his case against
indulgences.
And as such, against the authority of
the church and the Pope. And this is the
argument he makes, okay? So, let's look
at some sentences. In on So, the 36th
sentence is "Every truly repentant
Christian has a right to full remission
of penalty and guilt even while letters
are parted." Okay? And what he's saying
here is the idea of salvation by faith.
You don't have to spend this money. You
don't have to do what the what the
church tell us you If you are a true
Christian, if you truly believe believe
in God, God will forgive you.
You have direct access to God. Okay? So,
he's denying the authority of the Pope,
which makes him a heretic.
He also says, "Christians are to be
taught that the Pope in granting pardons
needs and therefore desires their devout
prayer for him more than the money they
bring." Okay? This is like an insult to
the Pope. He's saying like
the person that most offends God in this
world is the Pope.
Because the Pope is insulting God by
telling the world that the that that God
can be bribed by money.
Okay? So, let's pray for the Pope.
Because clearly the Pope um has offended
God.
He also says,
"Why does not the Pope, whose wealth is
today greater than the richest of the
richest?" He's saying the Pope is the
richest man in Europe. "Why doesn't the
Pope spend this money and build the
church himself?"
"Build just this one church of St. Peter
with his own money rather than with the
money of poor believers."
Okay? Why is he exploiting the poor when
he is the richest man in the world?
Okay? As you can see I And as you can
imagine, the the church is furious with
him. And they deem him a heretic, and
they want to burn him at the stake. But
again, he's protected by
powerful political patrons, and they
fight a war
um over this issue, and it ends with
something called the Peace of Augsburg,
which divides um the Holy Roman Empire,
Germany, into uh Lutheran
uh areas where they are free to believe
in Lutheran and Catholic areas where
they still adhere to the Pope. Okay?
So, this is the beginning of the
Protestant Reformation.
Um
Do Martin Luther
um starts
um this doctrinal debate, and John
Calvin also contributes to it by
introducing the idea of double pre-
predestination.
All right? So, Martin Luther, he wants
to reform the church.
And And then he eventually realizes that
he needs to build another church.
But John Calvin, with his idea of pre-
double predestination, he's trying to
She's trying to deny the authority of
the church. Okay? he's telling people
that because God has already decided who
will go to heaven
at the beginning of time, then the
church is lying to you. The church is
fooling you, deluding you.
Okay?
All right.
So, uh he's a Frenchman, he went to the
Sorbonne, the University of Paris, and
as you can imagine, he's deemed a
heretic, and he and he flees to a place
called Geneva in Switzerland. And
Switzerland is one of the birthplaces of
the Protestant Reformation. The reason
why is um there are a lot of independent
towns
in Switzerland. And as I mentioned,
um the first believers in the Protestant
religion are actually towns people.
That's aspirational middle class.
Okay, they want to they want to connect
with God, and they want a religion that
encourages them to achieve more in life.
And that's what the Protestant religion
is about.
Um there's also another uh famous
theologian that's really not not
discussed today, but he's considered one
of the three major founders of
Protestantism. His name is Ulrich uh
Zwingli, and he's based in Zurich, okay?
And he's probably the most extreme of
the three.
Okay. All right.
So, the Protestant Reformation, it opens
a kind of worms. It opens a Pandora's
Box. Because before the ultimate
authority was
the Pope, who represented God.
But now, you're free to believe whatever
you want.
So,
um there are lots of peasants who
rebelled against nobility
because they thought
that feudalism was evil in the eyes of
God, okay? So, this is a proto-communist
movement. These are people who wanted
total equality and democracy
and freedom in the world because they
believe that is the will of God.
Okay, so they rebel against the feudal
lords and kill them.
And then the entire
monarchy unite the aristocracy unite
because they see this see these peasants
as a threat. Okay? Now, there are lots
of these peasants. We estimate maybe
about 300,000 joining this rebellion.
But they are not educated. They are not
organized. They have no weapons.
And they have no centralized authority.
And therefore, they're all massacred
by
the aristocratic armies, okay?
All right, so this is the Peasants' War.
And this is important because eventually
we'll discuss communism.
And communism will be developed in
response to the Peasants' War, okay? So
this is the deadliest massacre of
peasants before the French Revolution.
Um 1534 is the Act of Supremacy. That is
when the king of England, Henry the
VIII,
declares his independence from
the Pope, okay?
But because there's such a strong
Catholic contingent in England,
um Henry the VIII maintains Catholic
practices. But rather than have the Pope
be at the head of the church, he himself
is now head of the church, okay? It's
called the Church of England now.
And the religion religion is called uh
Anglican the Anglican religion, okay?
The Anglican religion, all right?
Um so,
the thing
that we should observe
about the First Reformation is that,
first of all, it's extremely diverse,
okay? There are lots of different
denominations. The Lutherans are those
who believe
in Martin Luther, okay?
The Calvinists are those who believe in
double predestination.
The Anglicans are English who still
follow Catholic rituals, but rather than
follow the Pope, they follow the King of
England. Okay?
The Hussites are those who adhere to Jan
Hus. In Bo- Bohemia. The Unitarians are
interesting. Unitarians are those who
deny the divinity of Jesus.
They deny the Holy Trinity. God is God,
and Jesus is just the Messiah. He's just
a prophet of God. Okay? So, they affirm
the moral teachings of Jesus, but they
deny his divinity. You also have
uh the Anabaptists, okay? The
Anabaptists are interesting as well,
because they believe that to truly
believe in God, you must choose to do
so.
Therefore, you must not baptize infants.
Because when you do so, you force
children to believe in God, even though
they themselves lack the capacity, lack
the reason to believe in God.
Okay? So, only adults can join the
faith. And they must do so voluntarily.
All right? So, as you can see, there's
tremendous
um divergence, there's tremendous
diversity within the Protestant uh
faith. And it still still continues
today, okay? Every day you have new
denominations opening up, because people
are interpreting the Bible differently.
The another thing that you will notice
is that most of Protestants are actually
located in northern Europe.
All right? So, the countries of England,
Germany,
uh the Nordic countries,
Switzerland, they will go Protestant.
And in the south,
um
France, Spain, Italy, they will remain
Catholic. The only exception is this,
the south of France. Okay? The south of
France. The south of France will turn
Protestant.
It's interesting for us, because if you
look at a map, okay, the Protestant
uh French are heavily
centered in the south of France. And if
you remember from last week, that's
where the Cathars are also located,
okay? So, some historians believe that
um Protestantism
um and Cath- and Catharism, they sort of
mingle together. They combine and become
conflated together, okay? Other
historians believe that it's because
that culturally the south of France,
because it's um it's it's like
surrounded by mountains, it's always
been culturally independent
of um the rest of France. They speak a
local language called uh
Provençal, which is different from uh
French.
Okay?
Um
these Protestants in France
and sorry, these Protestants in France
um they're mainly in the middle class,
they're extremely well educated, they
become very prosperous,
and they join with the nobility. And as
such, the king of France, and France is
right now the most powerful country in
Europe, the king of France sees them as
a threat. And so, what he'll do is he'll
um
kill some of the nobles, which launches
the St. Bartholomew's Day's Massacre in
1572, okay? That's a day when tens of
thousands of French Protestants called
Huguenots were killed. And this was sort
of process by which these Huguenots,
extremely well educated, extremely hard
working, extremely wealthy, they will
move to Protestant countries like
England,
and the Netherlands, and Germany. And
they will help these countries
jump-start the Industrial Revolution.
Okay? They will bring their expertise
um and they will help these countries
jump-start the Industrial Revolution.
So, this is a tremendous loss for
France, tremendous gain for
um the other Protestant nations.
Okay.
So, um eventually
Europe is divided into two major
factions, the Catholic faction and the
Protestant faction. And these two
factions will eventually engage in
something called the Thirty Years' War,
okay, between the Habsburgs, okay, the
the Holy Roman Empire, which is
supported by the Pope, versus basically
the independent states of, um,
Germany, okay?
And this is a war that will last exactly
30 years. And again, it will kill at
most 8 million people. It's the
deadliest war in European history,
um, up until World War I.
Uh, what's interesting about this war is
that France, which is Catholic, chooses
to join the Protestants in this war
because they see the Holy Roman Empire
as an imperial threat. They're afraid
that if they allow the Habsburgs to take
over Germany, then eventually they will
start swallow up France, okay? So, it's
a religious war, but it it was also a
geo-geopolitical and imperial war.
All right? And again, um, this war ends
with the Treaty of Westphalia, which
guarantees religious freedom in Europe,
okay? So, the the religious wars will
end, and Protestant religion will now be
free to develop, um, independently.
Okay? So, this is called the Peace of
Westphalia.
Okay. So, um, now let's summarize and
let's, um,
discuss the evidence
for my argument that the Protestant
Reformation gave birth to capitalism.
Okay. So, um, these are the three major
differences between Catholic religion
and a Protestant religion. The question
then is, why is it
that the north will become mainly
Protestant and the south of Europe will
become will stay mainly Catholic, okay?
Um, so,
one thing that we discussed in this
class is the persistence of culture.
So, is it So, again, no one knows why
this is the case, okay? And you'll have
hear different arguments. It could have
been weather, it could have been uh
personality.
It It could have been a lot of different
factors, okay? But, one possibility I I
want to present to you today is the
cultural factor, which is that the south
of France and the north of France are
culturally different. All right? So,
let's look at south of France. South
Sorry, south of Europe. The southern
Europe countries of Spain, France, and
Italy were heavily influenced by Roman
culture. That's where the Roman Empire
was based, right? The Roman Empire
eventually became an imperial
bureaucracy. There are three core values
to the Romans, right? Liberty. Now,
liberty is really important. It means
obedience to the law. Because only by
obeying obeying the law can people be
free to do what they want, okay?
Secondly is the idea of republica.
Republica means public virtue.
To serve the public good. Which
basically means obeying what the Senate
tells you to do, okay? Obeying
authority. The last is the idea of
piety, which is to respect the customs
and history and traditions of Rome.
Okay, so these are the three major
values of the Romans.
And we can believe that they they became
embedded in the south of Europe. Now,
let's look at Viking culture, okay? And
when I say Vikings, I don't really mean
Vikings per se. What I really mean are
those proto-Indo-Europeans that never
really assimilated into Roman culture.
All right? So, what are their values?
Well, they believe in courage, they
believe in loyalty, and they believe in
resourcefulness, okay? And we discussed
this when we discussed the Vikings. Now,
what we're going to do is this. We're
going to map Catholic belief with
Romans, and we're going to map Viking
belief with the Protestants and see what
happens.
Okay. So, the Catholics, they believe in
orthodoxy, right?
Well, the Romans also believe in
orthodoxy. They call it liberty, right?
Obedience to laws. Don't question laws,
just obey them.
Um Catholics believe in hierarchy. Well,
Romans believe in hierarchy as well.
They believe in obeying the Senate.
The Senate is the ultimate authority,
right? Uh Catholics believe in
justification by works. Uh the Romans
believe in piety, right? Respecting
tradition. You don't have to believe in
these traditions, but you must respect
them. All right? So, this is pretty
close. I mean, it's not perfect. All
right? But, this suggests that uh Roman
culture had a tremendous influence on
development of the Catholic Church.
Now, let's look at the pro- the
Protestants, okay? They believed in
direct access to God through the Bible.
Well, the Vikings believed in courage.
What is courage? Courage is ex-
self-exploration. To go out in the
unknown and figure out things for
yourself, okay?
And that's what the Bible is. That's
what faith is. To read the Bible by
yourself and to interpret the Bible in
your own way.
And you have to do so using emotional
and spiritual courage.
All right?
Egalitarianism.
So, the Vikings had a concept of
loyalty.
And loyalty is basically the idea of
mutual love.
I'm loyal to you and you're loyal back
to me because we love each other. All
right? And the last concept is
justification by faith. An individual
struggle to come to terms with what God
means to you individually, okay? And
um the Vikings believed in
resourcefulness, right? Which is also
the idea of individual struggle. You can
figure out by yourself if you work hard
enough. If you will yourself, if you
have the courage to do so. Okay? So,
again,
um I leave this as a possibility.
Okay? Don't Don't treat this as a
historical fact.
I just suggest this as a way to think
about why
the Protestants became Protestants, the
Catholics became Catholics, okay? And a
lot of it has to do with the cultural
residue
from the past. Okay.
All right. So, this this is just a
thought experiment. All right. So, let's
start now talk about why is it that the
Protestant Reformation won out?
Again, they were up against
the Ro- uh the Holy Roman Empire. They
up They were up against Catholic Church.
Um there were more people in Catholic
Europe.
Catholic Europe was wealthier and
stronger, but they still won, okay? And
the reason why they won is due to the
invention of three things.
The first thing is the printing press,
which allowed for mass literacy and
education. Now, everyone could read the
Bible. Before, you couldn't do so. You
couldn't afford a Bible. But now,
everyone can read the Bible. But not
only that, but every- but everyone can
now become self-educated. You can read
all the classics by yourself. Okay?
And the Protestant religion compelled
you to be literate and to be educated.
And as such, the Protestants as a whole
were more well-educated than the
Catholics.
Okay? That's the first reason, the
printing press. Second reason is the
musket. This is really important.
Before, uh the main weapon, the ultimate
weapon, was a knight. The armored
knight.
And the armored knight was a
professional soldier.
All right? And that's why the knights
were the nobility because they had to
spend all their time uh training for
war, going to war, fighting wars.
Um and it's very expensive to be a
knight.
But now, eventually, you have the gun,
the musket. Okay? And it takes about 60
days for anyone to learn how to use the
musket. And the musket is The thing with
the musket that's really important is
it's able to pierce the armor of the
knight.
Which makes Which makes the knight
useless in war now, okay?
It's a musket that uh is important. So,
in other words, anyone who has courage
and devotion, mainly meaning the
Protestants,
they're able to fight a war. And the
musket will be vital, it will be crucial
for both the American Revolution and the
French Revolution, okay? And we'll we'll
discuss the musket when we get to the
American Revolution and the French
Revolution. The last thing is that you
have bank notes, okay?
Before uh people used gold
or coins that were minted with gold in
order to mint to trade goods. Now we you
can use bank notes, which is just money,
okay?
Um
and you can now monetize your hard work
and frugality. You can now channel your
hard work and frugality into bank notes.
What's really important now is there's
only a finite number of gold
and
coins, right? But there's an infinite
source of bank notes.
So you can work infinitely hard, okay?
So So what this means is
um before the Protestant Reformation,
it's really hard to get people to work
hard. Because let's just say that you
are an employer and you want to be like,
"Okay, I'm going to pay people more,
right?" Well, when you pay people more,
they actually work less.
Because they can't spend that money.
They're like, "Well, you know, if I have
to work 8 hours a day to make $100, but
now I I just work two two hours a day to
work to make $100, I'll just make I'll
just make I'll just work two hours." So
they actually work less. And in this
system, slavery makes sense.
Because
um the way to get people to work hard is
to force them into eternal debt, which
is what slavery is.
But in this new Protestant system,
then slavery is an evil. Because you're
denying people the capacity to be with
God, right? You are with God if you work
hard. But if you're a slave, how do you
measure the hard work? You You're not
able to work hard. And that's why um
after the Protestant Reformation, one of
the main things that they did was
eventually outlaw slavery.
Okay?
So, there are lots of good things about
about the Protestant Reformation. You
have the Industrial Revolution, you have
the end of slavery, you have the rise of
capitalism, you have the rise of the
middle class, you have lots of really
good things.
But, there's also no denying that there
are some bad effects as well, okay? All
right.
So, this is a printing press invented by
Gutenberg.
This is This is what a printing press
looks like.
You have the musket, okay?
So, before people had bows,
right?
And the bows um were used by trained
archers, and they weren't that powerful.
But, now with the musket, you're able to
pierce knight armor.
Okay? Because there's more energy.
Uh
3,100 joules within the bullet.
And then
you have
banknotes as well. And banknotes really
is the extraction of wealth,
okay? Which means that in theory now,
you could have infinite wealth.
Why are we Why are we so wealthy today?
Because we Because we abstracted wealth,
okay? Before, wealth was limited because
um
gold was limited. But, now with
banknotes, with money, in theory,
wealth can be
infinite, okay?
Okay.
So, this is John Wes- Wesley, who is the
founder of the Methodist Church, okay?
And he summarizes the
idea of Protes- Protestant really well.
We ought not to prevent people from
being diligent and frugal. We must
exhort all Christians to gain all they
can and to save all they can. That is,
in effect, to grow rich.
Right? So, Protestants believe that it
is God's calling,
it is your mission to get rich, and
that's how you know that you're favored
by God. All right? And the way to get
rich is by working hard and not spending
any money.
Okay.
So, what I'm going to do now
is present the evidence
for my argument that the Protestant
religion gave birth to capitalism. Okay?
And to do so, I'm going to I'm going to
refer to three major thinkers.
Max Weber,
Emile Durkheim, and Georg Simmel.
They're all sociologists. They're
considered the three major founders of
the social sciences.
Okay? And they they they're all
contemporaries. They they were all
writing about the year 1900.
Why this is important is the year 1900
is really when
the Protestant religion is most
triumphant. Right? This is when
capitalism is most dominant.
Even though most people are not
Protestants, Protestant
um the work ethic, the belief system has
conquered the world.
Germany,
Britain,
United States are the are the three most
powerful countries in the world at this
time.
They're the three largest empires.
And they're all Protestant nations. And
as such, they can impose Protestant
beliefs on everyone else.
Okay? And in the year 1900, it's also
be- before World War I.
So, at this time, everyone thinks that
this is the greatest thing in the world.
Protestantism,
Industrial Revolution, capitalism are
all
um divinely sent by God to bless
humanity, okay? And what Max Weber,
Georg Simmel, and Emile Durkheim are
trying to do is figure out
what's really going on, okay?
And to see if there are any consequences
to this system.
And what they will show us is in fact
there are a lot of problems in the
system, okay? So let's let's let's first
look at Max Max Weber who in 1904 to
1905 from 1905 he wrote something called
The Protestant Ethic and the Spirit of
Capitalism. He's trying to explain why
is it that Protestants are a lot
wealthier than Catholics in general,
okay?
And this is what he has to say.
So far as predestination was not
reinterpreted, toned down, or
fundamentally abandoned, okay? So
remember double predestination, right?
The belief that God has already selected
those who are going to heaven and you
must prove to yourself
that you're one of them.
Two principal mutually connected types
of pastoral advice appear.
Okay? So there are two consequences to
the idea of predestination.
On the one hand, it is held to be an
absolute duty to consider oneself
chosen, okay?
So when you know I mean no one is going
to heaven, the odds are you're not going
to heaven, but you must believe you're
going to heaven, otherwise you lack
faith in God.
Otherwise you don't truly believe in
God. And then and then therefore you'll
be truly damned,
condemned by God.
And to combat all doubts as temptations
of the devil, since lack of
self-confidence is the result of
insufficient faith, hence of imperfect
grace. Okay? To prove that God is
perfect, to prove that God loves you,
you must truly believe that you are
chosen by God.
If you doubt yourself, then you'll be
condemned to hell, okay? Then you become
a servant of the devil.
The exhortation of the apostle to make
fast one's own call is here interpreted
as a duty to attain certainty of one's
own election and certification in the
daily struggle of life, okay? So you
need to prove
that you are one of the elect by
focusing on this world. Okay, focus your
energies on conquering this world.
On the other hand, in order to attain
that self-confidence, intense worldly
activity is recommended as the most
suitable means. It and it alone
disperses religious doubt and gives the
certainty of grace. Okay? So, this idea
of all the You have anxiety? How do you
deal with anxiety? Work. Work. Work.
Okay? OCD, obsessive-compulsive
behavior. What kind of work do you do?
Make money.
Because the money is proof of God's
grace.
Right?
Okay, so he continues.
This worldly Protestant asceticism Okay,
asceticism just means like you're
actually not spending any money, okay?
Not only are you compelled to
make a lot of money, but you're also
compelled not to spend any of it.
Not to enjoy it, because that leads to
corruption.
That leads to decadence.
Acted powerfully against the spontaneous
enjoyment of possessions, it restricted
consumption, especially of luxuries.
Okay? So, no one's spending any any of
this money. Where's this money going?
It's going to the bank.
And who's using using this money in the
bank? The government is.
And what are they doing? They're using
it to fight wars.
Right? And that's how England, the
Netherlands
became empires. They had access to all
this surplus wealth that Protestants
weren't spending.
On the other hand, it had a
psychological effect of freeing the
acquisition of goods from the
inhibitions of traditionalist ethics.
Okay? So, the idea here is this.
Before, if you're wealthy, you're
expected by everyone around you to
support the community.
Usually by organizing feasts on
religious festivals, okay? You were
expected to share your wealth. If you
had too much money, it showed that you
were against the community.
Okay? It showed that you were selfish.
But now
people believe that
you're if you're wealthy, it means God
favors you.
The more wealth you have, the more
people respect you, okay? It's a
complete inverse from the historical
um
case.
Historically, we believed that those who
have too much money are evil. Now we
believe that those who have too much
money are inherently good. Okay? It's
completely reversed.
It broke the bonds of the impulse of
acquisition in that in that only
legalized it, but looked upon it as
directly willed by God, okay?
So before it's embarrassing to have too
much money, now it is prestigious to
have too much money.
The campaign against the temptations of
the flesh and the dependence on external
things was not a struggle against the
rational acquisition, but against the
rational use of wealth, okay? So what's
evil is not to make a lot of money.
What's evil is to use that money to
enjoy yourself.
All right?
Okay. So now he discusses the problems
with this
ideology, okay? The Puritan want to work
in a calling, okay? So the Puritans want
to be close to God.
We are forced to do so. We're not
Puritans. Most of the world is not
Puritans. We are stuck. We are in prison
in their world. They create this world
and we're stuck in it.
For when asceticism was carried out of
monastic cells into everyday life,
okay? So the idea was in the Catholic
Church, if you wanted to be a be an
ascetic, if you wanted to deny the
world, you went into a monastery.
The Puritans made the entire world into
a monastery, okay?
Um
and began to dominate worldly morality,
it did its part in building the
tremendous cosmos of the modern economic
order. He's talking about capitalism,
okay? So, capitalism was created by the
Puritans in order to rationalize the
world.
This order is now bound to the pinnacle
and economic conditions of machine
production, which today determine the
lives of all the individuals who are
born into this mechanism, not only those
directly concerned with economic
acquisition with irresistible force.
Okay? So, they create this system, which
is industrial production. This
industrial production has made us all
into slaves.
And the soul of this industrial
production system is capitalism, wealth
for the sake of
wealth.
Okay? And there's no denying this
system. You cannot You can never free
yourself from this system. You're stuck
inside of the system. But not only that,
but this entire of industrial uh
production
it has permeated into all aspects of
life. It's permeated into the family.
It's permeated into the school, okay?
Why do you have grades? Why do you have
Why do we have tests?
Because of this industrial economy.
Right? Grades tests are another form of
money.
Perhaps it will so determine them until
the last ton of fossilized coal is
burned, okay? What he's saying here is
that this system will keep on going
until we destroy the planet. Okay? And
we don't we run out of resources. But
because that's what capitalism is. It's
It's the exploitation of the
environment.
In Baxter's view, the care for external
goods should only lie on the shoulders
of the saint like a light cloak which
can be thrown aside at any moment, okay?
So, the idea of capitalism is, "Listen,
external wealth
wealth is just a measure of your faith
in God. That's what's important. What's
important is your faith, right? But
but the faith that create that the cloak
should become an iron cage.
Okay? Money was supposed to be a tool.
Money was supposed to be a mechanism for
us to connect with God. But now money,
capitalism, industrial production has
become our prison.
There's no There's no denying it. No one
can now escape this, okay?
Okay?
Does it make sense to you?
All right.
So now he makes predictions.
No one knows who will live in this cage
in the future, or whether at the end of
this tremendous development entirely new
prophets will arise, or there will be a
great rebirth of old ideas and ideals of
of neither mechanized petrification
embellished with a sort of convulsive
self-importance.
Okay? Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I read this
wrong, okay?
Let Let me do this again.
No one knows who will live in this cage
in the future, or whether at the end of
this tremendous development entirely new
prophets will arise, or there will be a
great rebirth of old ideas. Okay. So
what what we're saying is this.
As capitalism conquers more and more
territory, as it becomes more embedded
into everyday life, there will be
a nostalgia for the Catholic Church.
And there may arise new prophets who
will will rebel against capitalism just
like Martin Luther rebelled against the
Catholic religion, okay? And these new
ideas
will happen, they're called fascism
and communism.
All right? So capitalism will give rise
to the Nazis as well as the communists,
the Bolsheviks.
So this is the future, okay? So he's
making a prophecy.
But if these things don't happen, then
what then what will happen is this.
Mechanized petrification embellished
with a sort of compulsive
self-importance.
We believe today that we have achieved
divinity. We've achieved heaven on
Earth. Capitalism is the greatest good.
But, if you think about it, our
civilization has become a zombie
civilization. It is without soul. It is
without spirituality. It is without
heart. It's all machine. It's all money.
It's all obsession. Nothing else.
Okay?
So, um sorry that this is not appearing
properly, okay? But but that's that's
what he's saying here.
For of the last stage of this cultural
development, it might well be truly
said, "Specialists without spirit."
Okay?
We have scientists
who lack
purpose.
They have no
sense of divinity. They have no
sense of mission, okay? They're just
doing technical work. Scientists who
just do technical work.
Senseless without heart.
This no
This no lidity imagines that it has
achieved a level of civilization never
before achieved, okay?
All right?
So, that's what he's saying. He's saying
like our civilization, it is a zombie
civilization. It is annihilated. No, it
is nothing. It is It is nihilistic.
But we believe
this is perfection.
Okay?
And if you think about it, he's
describing perfectly the world we live
in today.
It's perfect, okay? He's He wrote this
in about 1900.
He predicted this
would happen. And then he's right.
We live in a zombie civilization.
All right. Okay.
So, um this is Georg Simmel, who is a
friend of Max Weber's.
They're contemporaries. They're
colleagues. They're friends.
Um and he's trying to explain where
money comes from, okay? And I I
explained previously money now has
become a substitute for the idea of God.
It's become reality itself. Okay, and
how and why is that? Okay, here he
explains it.
The projection of mere relations into
particular objects is one of the great
accomplishments of the mind, okay? So,
we're able to take an idea and transpose
this idea onto a thing. Okay, we're
we're able to take the idea of God and
turn it into money. Okay, we can do that
and that's a great thing.
When the mind is embodied in objects,
these become a vehicle for the mind
endowed with a livelier and more
comprehensive activity. Okay, when we do
this, we turn God into money,
our instead of reality becomes much more
vibrant. We're able to understand
reality much better.
Okay?
The ability to construct such symbolic
objects attains its greatest triumph in
money.
Okay, money becomes a placeholder for
everything.
All right?
For money represents pure interaction in
its purest form. How do we know
if we're working hard? How do we know if
we are succeeding? How do we know if we
have friends? Through money, okay?
Through capital accumulation.
It makes comprehensible the most
abstract concept. It is an individual
thing whose essential significance is to
reach beyond individualities.
It centralizes everything, okay?
Everyone agrees on money.
Thus, money is the adequate expression
of the relationship of man to the world
which can only be grasped in single and
concrete instances. Yet, only really can
see when the singular becomes the
embodiment of the living mental process
which interweaves all singularities and
in this fashion creates reality, okay?
So, uh at the at the beginning of class
I talked about money, right? How money
um takes all our different perspectives
and converges into one thing, okay? And
then it it redesigns reality through
this lens. Okay, that's what he's saying
here, okay?
Uh the last person I want to talk about
is Emile Durkheim. And he's a French uh
sociologist and his most famous book is
called On Suicide.
He's He's trying to discuss
why is it that Protestants are much more
likely to kill themselves than
Catholics.
Okay?
And his um
answer is it's because Protestants
believe you have to struggle
individually with faith. Whereas
Catholics don't believe that. Catholics
believe that you just follow community
rituals and you're good. Okay? So
Protestants feel that they are alone
and abandoned in this world and that
they they must
struggle out of this darkness.
And that leads to tremendous energy,
okay? But it also leads sometimes to
self-defeat.
It leads to hopelessness and that's why
they kill themselves.
Okay, so so so let's not read this but
but that's what he's saying, okay?
Okay, but I want to read this.
This is really important. He's talking
about the fact that Protestants transfer
this um anxiety in the accumulation of
wealth, right? They're anxious about
what God is. They're anxious whether or
not God loves them and they uh focus on
the accumulation of wealth. Okay? And
this is a problem because
overexcited ambitions always exceeds the
results that they achieve, whatever
these may be, because they have not been
aware that they should not go any
further. Okay.
Right? Let's just say that you want to
lose weight.
Your obsession is to lose weight.
It's possible that you may die in the
process because
you don't know
how much weight you should lose.
You don't know
what the proper equilibrium is, okay?
You just want to lose as much weight as
possible. That's the problem with
accumulating money.
You try to get more and more money to
prove your worth to God, but you can't
stop. You don't know when to stop.
Okay?
Consequently,
nothing satisfies them, and all this
agitation perpetually sustains itself
without reaching any form of satiety.
You cannot stop, okay? You look at uh
Jack Ma, the richest man in China at
some point, right?
He has all this money, $50 billion.
What is he doing with it? Nothing. All
he wants to do is make more and more
money. Why? Because only the acquisition
of money brings him happiness. Nothing
else does.
It's a disease.
Above all, as this race towards an
unattainable goal can give no
satisfaction, but the race itself, if
that can be called satisfaction,
should anything chance to get in its
way, then one is left empty-handed.
Okay?
You're so focused on the obtaining of
wealth
that if you lose
this process, okay? You stop this
process,
you will feel devoid of everything,
okay? You could have $50 billion in the
bank, but you but you drop out of this
race, you stop the accumulation of
money, you will fall into anxiety and
depression.
Right?
Now, it so happens that at this time,
the struggle becomes more violent and
more painful, both because it is less
regulated and because competition is
fiercer.
All right, so he's talking about
capitalism.
How? Because it's all about the
accumulation of wealth, and the
accumulation of wealth can only bring
about more anxiety and more stress.
It's It's bringing down all social
bonds. Okay? It's bringing all
traditional morality. It's bringing
bringing down all customs and norms.
All classes are caught up in it because
there's no longer any established
classification. If you're rich, if
you're poor, you're stuck in the system.
No matter how rich you are, you're still
playing this game. You can never escape
it.
So, the effort is all the greater at the
moment when it becomes more
unproductive.
How can the will to live not be weakened
in these conditions? Okay. So,
I
Like I know this is hard and I know what
what what what what what I'm saying is
going to is going to be depressing,
but
what Max Weber is saying is we live in a
zombie civilization.
Okay? That's what he's saying.
What Emile Durkheim is saying is that
this civilization is on a on a path to
suicide.
It's on a path to self-destruction.
Because there's no purpose in this
civilization.
It's all This we exist for the sake of
accumulating
nothing of value.
And eventually
we'll just
recognize this
and we'll opt to die. Our civilization
is on a path to suicide. And you know
what?
They're right. They're prophets. Think
about this.
Never before in human history
have we been as wealthy
as
technological progress, right? With the
internet.
As more connected. We can fly all around
the world. You can go to United States
and study and then come back and work,
okay? You have more opportunities than
ever before. But again, think about
this, okay?
Never before in human history have there
been more depression and anxiety,
more suicides,
more feeling of disconnection.
Okay?
So,
think about this. Let's do a thought
experiment.
Let's just say that
I have anxiety. And the way that I deal
with this anxiety is I collect
newspapers.
Every day I'm out collecting newspapers.
I fill this room with newspapers, and
then I go next to me and fill with
newspapers.
Everyone would say that I am hoarding,
okay? The word is hoarding, and it is a
disease.
Right? It's a disease. We all know We
all know it's a disease. If I were to go
talk to a psychologist, he would he
would say, "I'm I have a disease. I need
I need to
take some anxiety medication. I need to
relax, go on vacation, whatever, okay?"
But, let's just say this. Let's say I I
have anxiety, and all I want to do is
make money.
I make a million dollars. I don't spend
it. I put it in the bank, and I go make
two million dollars.
And then I go make three million
dollars. And I'm not spending it. It's
all in the bank, okay?
How is that different from hoarding?
How is that different from me collecting
newspapers and just putting it in the
house? It's not. There's no difference,
right? But,
everyone would think
I'm a great person.
I am a good person because I'm working
hard and I'm saving money.
Right?
It's a contradiction in our society.
It's a contradiction that exists because
our society our civilization is
incapable of recognizing that we are a
zombie civilization that is on the path
to
civilizational suicide.
All right?
Okay.
So,
this was depressing,
but
I feel as though
we needed to
um discuss this, okay? And again, um the
same ideas that we learned previously,
we're combining it, and and we are going
to use these ideas to understand the
future development, okay?
All right. So,
um any questions?
You know, I have several questions.
Great.
Um
the first one is like
um the Protestants are more likely to
commit suicide.
Yep.
Um I believe that
it's believed in
Christianity that suicide is a sin.
Okay.
You're absolutely right, okay? You're
absolutely right. That That So, in the
Catholic religion, suicide is the worst
sin that you can commit,
okay? And in the Protestant religion,
there are also
um mechanisms against suicide.
But, let's go back to the theory. The
theory is
double predestination.
God has already
decided who will be burned in hell and
who will go to heaven. And only a
minority can go to heaven, right? And
there's nothing you can do
to change this.
Do you understand? So, if you follow the
logic, you commit suicide, you're doing
God's will because you commit suicide
because you don't believe in God or you
don't have enough faith in God, which
means that you were condemned anyway.
Okay? So, suicide, it's not a sin, it's
a sign of weakness.
Does that make sense?
Okay?
But, um also what's important for us to
remember is that suicide
is also a feeling of disconnection.
It It's a belief that no one cares if
you die or not.
No one supports you in your life and
therefore you're better off dead.
When you If you die, you're not actually
impacting the community, okay?
And And that's Emile Durkheim's
argument. You're always going to have
people kill themselves in all religions.
There's You can't really stop that. But,
Protestants are more likely to kill
themselves because Protestant is a much
more individualistic uh religion than
Catholic.
Okay?
All right.
Does that make sense?
Great. Okay.
Next question?
Um
You mentioned three
um
like
philosophers I believe.
Okay. So, these three are not
philosophers. These two are
sociologists. So, they're social
scientists. They're Max Weber, who is
considered the founder of sociology,
uh Georg Simmel,
um and Emile Durkheim. These These are
the three major sociologists
that uh really
um created modern social sciences, okay?
And they they um
They all notice a lot of problems, but
um
do they have any idea like providing
potential solutions?
Okay, that's a great question, okay? Um
Okay.
So, these are social scientists.
And the thing about social scientists is
they feel their responsibility is to
diagnose problems.
And once they diagnose problems,
then it's up to us
to figure out the solution, okay? So, so
so let's let's figure out what they're
saying, okay?
So,
um Weber is saying that
this anxiety,
which leads to capitalism,
will ultimately to
civilizational decline.
Okay?
That's his main argument. Okay? So, it
it it's again, like he's not writing at
the beginning of Protestantism, where
Prot- Protestantism was a persecuted
religion.
Um and where
um it really gave hope
to a lot of people. And it it really
empowered them to transform their lives,
okay? He's really talking about late
Protestantism, when it's really
conquered the world. And he he's seeing
a lot of issues.
Okay? And so,
he's looking at this. He's looking at
the anxiety which causes
capitalism which causes civilization to
decline. So, he says there has to be a
response.
And there's going to be past three
possible responses, okay? The first
possible response is nothingness, okay?
In which case, guess what? We we become
a zombie society.
A zombie society just means that
we just go on day to day doing whatever,
but we don't know why.
We don't really care. We have no soul.
We have no spirit. We have no energy,
okay? That's what a zombie society is.
And that And that's what he's afraid of.
But it's also possible
that there is a
uh reaction,
okay? Which will lead to the return of
the Catholic Church,
which was basically a theocracy.
It Does that make sense? That's the
second possibility. And then another
possibility is that of new prophets,
or people who are trying to channel this
discontent with capitalism in order to
form new movements in the way that
Martin Luther and John Calvin did,
right? And in the 12th century, there
were
two major responses to the problem of
capitalism. The first, of course, is
called communism.
The second is called fascism, okay, with
the Nazis.
All right. So, the 20th century was
really about defeating
these two critics of capitalism,
right? That's what the 20th century
really was about.
You first had World War II, which
defeated Nazism, and then you have the
Cold War, which defeated communism. All
right? So, this is out.
Okay? So, right now, okay, our two our
two paths ahead of us is either a zombie
society or the or a return to a
theocracy.
And so,
if I'm a betting man what our future
looks like,
I think it is most likely the world
becomes a theocracy.
All right? And there are theocracies
that exist today. So, for example, let's
look at North Korea. North Korea is a
theocracy
where
people are not allowed to think for
themselves.
People must do what they're told.
Okay? And it's all very heavily
ritualized society which worships the
divinity of the supreme leader.
We may
hate this society. We may be disgusted
by by this society, but guess what?
Okay, this is really important.
People in North Korea,
even though they're poorer,
even though they have less freedom,
they are on average happier and more
fulfilled and more energetic
than
most societies. You can You can compare
compare North Korea with South Korea,
okay? Right? In South Korea, no one's
having kids.
That's a sign of complete hopelessness
in the society.
North Korea, they're having a lot of
kids.
That's a sort of faith in their society.
Okay? So, that's what Max Weber is
predicting. He's predicting these three
possible paths. We tried the new private
path, didn't work. Okay? We don't want
to become a zombie society. So, the only
path ahead of us is to become a
theocracy.
A return to the tyranny
of the Catholic Church.
But the tyranny gives us meaning,
purpose, and spirituality, a connection
with God
that we are lacking into this into this
into this society.
Okay? But, okay, let's just say, for the
sake of argument,
you know what? Um
I like my individual freedom. Right? I
don't want to I don't want to go to to a
theocracy
where everyone's a slave.
What can we do about this?
Um
Okay, so one issue that Max Weber
doesn't really address because he
doesn't recognize the problem is
all these problems we're talking about
is a problem of mass society.
Okay?
When you have mass society, your options
are much more limited. When you have
mass society, you need to feed millions
and millions of people. You need to
organize them. You need to give them
something to do.
Therefore, your political flexibility
doesn't really exist.
Okay? So, in other words,
okay?
Thinking ahead, there are two solutions.
Either you become a theocracy
or you figure out the problem of mass
society.
Okay? If society becomes
I mean, like I'm sorry to say this, but
like if most people in the world died,
then we would have more freedom in this
world.
Okay? But if But if we choose to
continue the system where we have 8
billion people struggling
on this Earth, then you're stuck with
moving towards a
theocracy.
Okay?
So, that's what Max Weber is saying.
He's basically
um giving us a prophecy about our
future.
All right? Now,
okay, having said that,
let's look at
Durkheim. Okay? Durkheim.
What's he saying?
He's saying this, okay? This is really
important, okay?
Um it's a hard argument, but this is
what he's saying.
All right.
Why do you have suicide?
Suicide is the result of of
disconnection.
If we do not think we are valuable in
the world, if we think that we are alone
in this world, we don't want to be part
of this world. We kill ourselves, okay?
It's very simple idea, right?
But then the question then is, why is it
disconnection?
Because of anxiety, right?
It's It's a belief that if I don't work
hard,
God will not favor me.
Right?
Why is anxiety important? Because it
leads to capitalism.
So, in other words,
these four concepts are interconnected.
All right?
Disconnection leads to suicide. We have
disconnection because of anxiety. But
anxiety is what feeds capitalism. If
people weren't anxious, they wouldn't go
out and work so hard to make money,
right? They'd be like, "You know what?
I'm pretty happy making my $10 a day and
sit at home and eating noodles because I
don't care."
Right? Your society would collapse.
Capitalism would collapse.
Okay, so you have to So, you understand.
Capitalism creates suicide. That's why
we have the highest suicide rate in the
whole in in entire human history, okay?
More anxiety, more depression, more
suicide, more unhappiness, more
loneliness than ever before in human
history.
Okay?
So,
you can't say capitalism capitalism is
the issue, but if you work out the
logic, capitalism is the issue.
Right? And that's why
today in the United States and elsewhere
in the world, they're talking about a
return to a theocracy.
Because that was the direct response to
capitalism is a theocracy.
Let us all obey the church, and we're
good.
Okay?
Now, women will have to stay at home and
uh give birth to kids. Oh, and also like
if you're homosexual we're we're we're
going to have to kill you. But you know,
that's the price we we're going to pay,
okay? So it's a terrible world that
we're going to.
But what Durkheim is saying is
if we continue on the path of capitalism
people are going to choose the path of
theocracy. Theocracy theocracy is almost
a natural outcome of capitalism because
of the problem of disconnection.
Okay?
But are you going to be able to defeat
capitalism ever? And the answer is no,
okay? We tried in the 20th century. It
led to the death of tens of millions of
people.
Okay? Good luck trying to defeat
capitalism.
You can't do it. It can't be done. It's
too powerful.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Any more questions?
Okay, great. So
um
next Tuesday we do the same revolution,
okay?
All right.